SITUATIONS.
NUMBER TWO, ADMIRAL TAYLOR.
KARL ST INTO THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
IS COMING.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO GET
BLOCKER SAVED.
PICKED UP
>> ChrisBEHIND THE NET,
LOOKING FOR HELP.
FORSBERG FAKES THE SHOT.
SEND IT THROUGH! CARRIER HAD A
GOES AND GETS HIS OWN REBOUND-
IT.
>> Chris:
DISASAMMY GIRARD .
>> Chris: THE TRIGGER MAN.
JOSI BRINGS IT OUT TOP.
10 SECONDS TO GO  TO GO.
GLASS OUT TO TOLVANEN.
TOLVANEN AND FORSBERG  ON THE
FLANKS.BENNING WHO WAS
INJUFROM THAT SPOT.
SLAMMED ON THE BRAKES.
PUCK COMES OUT HIGH.
COLE SMITH DOWN LOW. FORSBERG W
USING THE FORWARD BUILDING
GLASS GETS IT BACK.
FABBRO AROUND THE
SISSONS, KNOCKED DO HAPPENS.
YOU SEE THE ACCELERATION.N, THE
FAR OFF BY SAROS.
BIG REBOUNDS.
ANOTHER SHOT.
GIRARD  TOIS A 3-2 HOCKEY
JEANNOT  TO THE MIDDLE. GOAL
THIS IS BY THE CAPTAIN.
ZONE ENTRY.
THE PUCK IT.
EKHOLM.
THE EMPTY-NET GOAL.